so let's quickly go through the
properties of exponents and then we'll
get into some more challenging examples
so the first thing we want to know is
that whenever you have a quantity to the
0 power what does that equal
well that's called 1 when you have a
negative exponent like we have here X to
the negative 2 what that negative
exponent tells us to do is to take the
reciprocal so what you can think of this
as as 1 over X to the second and for
product of powers when you're
multiplying and you have that same base
see how these are both X when you
multiply what do you do to the exponents
you add them together so that's going to
be like M plus N and quotient of powers
this is when you're dividing and you
have that same base the other both base
X you subtract the exponents and the
order is important you want to do the
numerators power minus the denominators
power okay and then power of a power
this is when you're raising an exponent
to another exponent you actually
multiply these powers together that's
going to be M times N and then power of
a product here's where you have like a
monomial like we're just one quantity in
the parenthesis what you do is you
distribute that power to the powers or
the exponents of the quantity inside so
for example here we have XY all to the M
that's going to be X to the M times y to
the M and then the last one the power of
a quotient we've got a quotient we have
a fraction right raised to a power what
you want to do is you want to distribute
that power to the numerator and the
denominator so this is going to be X to
the M over Y to the M ok let's jump into
some examples here now the first one
we've got 2 x squared Y all raised to
the 0 power what do you think that
equals well like we talked about here
with the 0 property of exponents
anything to the 0 power equals just 1 so
that was kind of an easy one for number
2 we've got 3 to the negative 3 power
okay so what do we do on this one well
what you can think of is any quantity
can be written as a fraction by putting
it over 1 and when you see that negative
exponent what you do is you take that
quantity and you move it to the other
side of the fraction bar and make it a
positive exponent so this is going to be
1 over 3 to the positive 3 now
and then we say well what's three cubed
that's three times three times three
that's 27 so this is one over
twenty-seven another way you can do this
problem is you could say three cubed is
27 and then because it has that negative
exponent take the reciprocal and you'll
still get 120 seventh for number three
we've got negative four squared all
divided by 5 to the negative two this is
getting a little bit more challenging
we've got a couple things going on here
we have this negative exponent here in
the denominator so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take this quantity I'm
going to move it to the other side of
the fraction bar that's just like taking
the reciprocal I'm going to make it
positive so we have negative 4 squared
times 5 to the positive 2 now the other
thing you want to pay attention to is
the order of operations you want to do
the parentheses which there's none then
exponents and then multiplication
division right so here what we have to
do is we have to do 4 squared which is
16 then times a negative so some people
be saying Mario well isn't a negative 4
squared 16 positive 16 well that's only
if this was in parentheses so if we were
taking it as a group but in this case we
want to do the 4 squared first that's 16
times a negative which is negative 16 5
squared which is 25 and these are
multiplied together that's going to give
us negative 400 ok for number 4 we have
3 X to the 0 Y to the negative fourth
what do you think you would get for that
one well again I always like to if it's
not a fraction write it as a fraction by
putting it over 1 this way if I see that
negative exponent I can take just that
quantity here now not the whole thing
just it's affecting just the Y here just
the base move that to the other side of
the fraction bar and make it positive so
now we have 3 X to the 0 all over Y to
the positive 4 now this 0 here you don't
want to make this whole numerator 1 that
would be if this was in parentheses the
whole quantity was to the 0 power you
just want to say well what's X to the 0
power that's going to be 1 times 3
equals 3 over Y to the fourth and you
got it ok for number 5 we've got 6 to
the negative 2 times X to the 4th over Y
to the negative third so what would you
do on this one well okay we see we have
a negative exponent so we're going to
move that to the
numerator we see that the 6 to the
negative 2 is a negative exponent we're
gonna move that to the denominator okay
but this is X to the positive 4 that's
going to stay put that's going to stay
right where it's at in the numerator so
let's look what we have so far we've got
X to the fourth times y to the positive
3 now because we move to the other side
of the fraction 6 to the negative 2 came
down so now that's 6 to the positive 2
of course 6 squared we know is 6 times 6
which is 36 and we've got X to the
fourth and y to the third in the
numerator number 6 we have 7 to the
fifth power divided by 7 to the third
power when you divide and you have that
same base what do you do to the
exponents
well you subtract them and you want to
make sure you do the numerator minus the
denominator so 5 minus 3 is 2 then we
have 7 squared which is 7 times 7 and we
get 49 so for number 7 we've got 2 to
the negative third times 2 to the
positive 8 when you multiply and you
have that same base in this case base 2
what do you do to the exponents well you
add them so negative 3 plus 8 is 5 and
then we know that 2 to the fifth is 2
times 2 times 2 times 2 times 2 which
equals 32 for number 8 we've got X to
the negative 2nd power all raised to the
3rd power okay now what do we do here
well you can see that we just have that
one base so you just X but we have a
power raised to a power so we multiply
the exponents together negative 2 times
3 is negative 6 but when you have that
negative exponent remember how we said
that you move it to the other side of
the fraction okay you take the
reciprocal and make it a positive
exponent so this is 1 over X to the 6th
and that's our final result there for
number 9 we've got kind of a combination
situation okay when you multiply and
have the same base what do you do to the
exponents you add so 3 plus 4 is 7 when
you divide okay and you have the same
base what do you do to the exponents you
subtract and again remember the order is
important its numerator minus
denominator so that's 7 minus negative 5
which when you subtract a negative it's
like adding the opposite so that's X to
the 12th for number 10 we've got
negative 3y squared all raised to the
fourth power now this one is a little
bit more challenging because
when you have a negative to an even
power so you've got four negatives
negative times negative times negative
times negative so a negative to an even
power gives us a positive so that's
going to give us negative three to the
fourth which is 81 and then here we have
a power to a power so what do we do we
multiply that's going to be Y to the
eighth and you got it now one thing I
want to point out here is that if you
don't see an exponent you can always
write one okay as the exponent and what
I'm doing is C I'm distributing or
multiplying this four on the outside to
the two and to the one so 4 times 1 is
just 4 so that's how I got 3 to the
fourth and a negative 4 times gave us a
positive number 11 we've got negative x
squared divided by 4 all to the negative
third power now this one what I'm gonna
do is you see that negative exponent
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take the
reciprocal of the base I'm gonna take
this whole base and flip it over that's
4 over negative x squared all to the
positive 3 now okay so the negative you
take your occipital base now we have a
quotient to a power so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna distribute that power to
the numerator and the denominator now
notice this 4 is really like 4 to the
first when you have a power to a power
like that you multiply the exponents
that's going to be 1 times 3 which is 4
cubed and here we've got x squared okay
to the third so power to power you
multiply again that's gonna be X to the
sixth notice we have a negative to an
odd power that's three negatives
multiplied together which is going to
give us a negative ok now 4 cubed is 4
times 4 times 4 that's 64 over negative
x to the sixth and that's our final
result for that one number 12 we've got
2 a to the negative 3 all raised to the
negative 4 so there's a couple different
ways to do this problem but I think I'm
gonna do on this one is think of this as
2 to the 1st and I'm going to distribute
that negative 4 okay like so so 1 times
negative 4 is negative 4 negative 3
times negative 4 is positive 12 you can
always think of this as being a fraction
by putting it over 1 because anything
divided by 1 is itself and then because
we have that negative exponent I'm going
to move it to the other side of the
fraction bar and make it positive so
this is really going to be 2 to the paws
4 which is 2 times 2 times 2 times 2
that's 16 so you're gonna get a to the
12th over 16 for number 13 a little bit
more challenging here we've got 3 R
squared s to the negative 3rd all over
12 R to the fifth s to the negative 4th
a couple different ways to do this
problem one is I could distribute that
power you know in like to all these
exponents multiply those together
and then simplify or maybe what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to try to
simplify what's on the inside first then
raise it to the power so 3 over 12 I
could reduce that to 1/4 okay so that's
we've got so far 1 over 4 when you
divide you subtract so 2 minus 5 gives
us R to the negative 3 sometimes
students get confused they say Mario do
I put the R to the negative 3 in the
numerator of the denominator well when
you do the quotient rule you divide
right so you subtract the exponents but
the answer always goes in the numerator
now on the next step because it's a
negative exponent I can move it to the
other side of the fraction bar make it a
positive 3 but I usually try to do one
step at a time so now we have s to the
negative 3 divided by s to the negative
4 negative 3 minus negative 4 is really
like negative 3 plus 4 which gives us 1
so that's asked to the first ok and that
whole thing is still raised to the
second power so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to distribute that power in
like so okay so 1 squared we know is 1
negative 3 times 2 is R to the negative
sixth 1 times 2 is 2 that's s squared
and then 4 squared because see this is
like 1 1 times 2 is 2 4 squared is 16
the only thing we need to do now is take
this R to the negative 6 take the
reciprocal meaning we're gonna move it
to the denominator and so I'm gonna
erase this ok and then we're gonna put
the R to the 6 in the denominator and
that's our final result you don't need
to have the 1 here 1 times anything is
itself
I'll just simplify that down a little
bit further last question see if you can
do this one it's very challenging
there's a lot of steps but we'll do it
together so here we've got as we've got
these two fractions multiplied together
ok as well as being raised to these
powers so here I'm going to do is I'm
going to take the 2 I'm going to
multiply it in like so okay
what I have is 2 times 2 is 4 3 times 2
is 6 3 squared is 9 because really see
how this is a 1 3 2 the first 1 times 2
is 2 3 squared is 9 and then we've got Y
to the negative fourth because negative
2 times 2 for this one what I'm going to
do is instead because I have a negative
exponent here is I'm going to take the
reciprocal to base I'm going to take the
reciprocal of this fraction here and
write this as 2x over 5 X Y to the
negative 2 and now it's all raised to
the positive 3 because that negative
just told us to take the reciprocal okay
let's go ahead and simplify what we have
here now so this is really like 1 1 1 1
right if you don't see the exponents
like a 1 power to power we multiply
right and we have a this one over here
we have a power of a product right see
product these are multiplied about the
raised to a power we're just multiplying
those exponents by 3 same thing with the
denominator as well so this is going to
come out to 2 cubed which is 8 X to the
3rd 5 cubed which is 125 X 1 times 3 is
3 so that's x cubed and then this is
negative 2 times 3 which is y to the
negative sixth ok and then over here
let's just bring this down we've got X
to the fourth Y to the sixth all over 9
Y to the negative fourth so now we're
just going to multiply horizontally
across so 8 times 1 gives us 8 X to the
fourth times X cubed when we multiply we
add exponents and the Y to the 6 comes
along and then over here we have 9 times
125 which is 1125 X cubed and then Y to
the negative 6 times y to the negative
fourth we add those exponents together
we get Y to the negative 10th okay now
we've got it all in two just like one
fraction and what we can do here is we
can see if we can reduce the fraction it
doesn't look like we're going to be able
to but when we divide here with the X's
and the Y's we subtract the exponents so
7 minus 3 is going to give us X to the
fourth 6 minus negative 10 when we
subtract a negative is like adding the
opposites Y to the positive 16
and then we have the 1125 in the
denominator and that's your final result
if you want to see more examples of
working with the properties or rules of
exponents follow me over to that video
right there and we'll get some more
examples in